[Music]
shanghai residents are finally out on
the streets celebrating the end of a
strict two months lockdown
[Music]
but it might not be the last time they
have to go through this
as china clings to what it calls a
dynamic zero copy strategy people can
face stringent lockdowns any time they
arise in cases where they leave
in shanghai residents were basically
locked up at home for weeks
shops schools and offices were closed
the lives of 25 million people were put
on hold
the social and economic consequences of
these tough restrictions have been
painful
and the suffering might seem very
unnecessary especially when the rest of
the world has basically returned to
normal
so why is china sticking to its zero
covet policy
the answer is that it has little choice
china's failure to capitalize on its
early pandemic success and adapt to
different circumstances today means is
now stuck
to understand why we need to go back to
the very beginning of the pandemic
remember wuhan the city where the
coronavirus was first found
it was also the first city in the world
to enter a covet lockdown
and by december 2020 while most
countries were still battling
devastating outbreaks
life for the city's 11 million people
was back to normal
that's thanks to a strict lockdown that
was imposed right after the corvette
outbreak
in china that their first objective is
to keep the virus out of the community
as much as possible with travel
restrictions and then if the virus does
get in which we know what happens sooner
or later
when there's an outbreak in a particular
community there's very stringent control
measures case finding
isolation of cases contact tracing and
quarantine and that's facilitated as
well typically by lockdowns
professor cullen is an epidemiologist
based in hong kong where pandemic
measures have been mostly in line with
mainland china
the city has been pretty much kovy free
until recently it's a very efficient
strategy compared to other strategies
because as long as most of the time can
be spent at zero daily cases actually
life can be pretty normal inside cities
in china
in fact china's initial approach was so
effective that it was regarded
internationally as a successful example
to learn from
professor jane duckett spent 18 months
with her team funded by the uk
government looking into china's pandemic
strategy back in 2020. i think it was
successful in the beginning obviously in
the sense that they they got the
infections and death um death rate back
down to zero from around late march
2020 but what was effective then is now
much less so
with the arrival of the more
transmissible omegran variant
it has become much more difficult to
stop the spread of the virus even with
measures like lockdowns
countries like singapore and new zealand
which initially adopt their own zero
cove policies have changed tech and are
now trying to live with the virus
but china has not
its success story back in 2020 has
arguably become the biggest hurdle in
the way of a more flexible approach
today in 2022
a major reason for china's hesitation to
open up is that the vaccination rate
among its elderly population is
exceptionally low
and that's largely due to the
consistently low number of infections i
think in a sense the successful
containment
made the vaccination especially of older
people seem less necessary right if you
don't have it spreading through society
you don't seem to need vaccines
only 19.7 of people above the age of 18
in china have received a vaccination
booster
while just over 50 percent of them have
completed their primary vaccinations
i suppose you could say they trusted the
government to protect them as long as
the xero kova strategy continues then
the public health measures are limiting
infections and so vaccines would be like
a back-up plan but um it may be not an
urgent priority for older adults a
recent study published by shanghai's
fudan university claims that with the
currently low vaccination rate among
elderly people
the lifting of the zero cove policy
could lead to over 1.5 million deaths
china could have pushed for a more
aggressive vaccination campaign before
the omicron variant appeared
missing that window has resulted in the
struggle it's facing today
that wasn't really planning for the
future and wasn't really planning for
the contingency of a more transmissible
variant as we've seen on top of that
there's a question of vaccine efficacy
research has shown that the chinese-made
inactivated virus vaccines are less
effective against infections with
omicron than mrna vaccines like for
example the visor beyond that vaccine
but china still hasn't approved the use
of foreign-made vaccines for its
population
instead it is betting on home-grown mlna
vaccines which are still undergoing
clinical trials
and that seems to be driven purely by by
political
decisions you know political motives to
not want to be seen to be reliant on
international support international
science and technology but to be able to
develop their own vaccines and use them
this possibility of high death rates and
infections if china drops its zero
co-feed approach is just too risky for
the ruling communist party a lot of how
people see 20
c covid 2020 2021
is in comparison with the west you know
so
in countries like the united states and
western european countries coveted rates
were very high death rates were very
high
people had waves of lockdown and
a lot of political disturbances and you
know it just felt like chaos in the west
whereas china was relatively peaceful
and have very low death rates
professor nancy chen is currently based
in the u.s
she has been observing and writing about
china's covet
think that's what the strategy
want to avoid and they just don't know
how i mean they can't avoid it
completely they have to find they're
trying to find the path
of minimal political cost
and the political cost of abandoning the
zero kofi strategy currently seems to be
too high
it has become president xi's signature
policy
he is expected to announce his intention
for landmark third term at china's 20th
party congress coming up in september
so it would be bad timing for a game
bowl on a new way to handle the pandemic
they
think that they have demonstrated the
superiority of the system in containing
the virus
and therefore they would like they would
like to continue with that and they
think they can continue with that
but the costs of continuing with the
policy are growing
the stringent kofi strategy is taking
its toll not only on people's daily
lives but also on china's economy
and that too will tarnish the ruling
party's popularity
is there a way then for china to both
transition out of its zero kovi strategy
and save the party's image
i believe that it should be possible for
them to find
a face-saving way to message this right
it's all about the messaging to say look
there's going to be some risks but if we
don't open up there are other types of
risks and others constantly have to pay
the difficulty is that the longer they
go on as they are now
the harder it will be for them to do
that messaging effectively because the
longer they go on like they do now the
more unhappy people are and the less
people trust the government
and this all leaves xi jinping and the
communist party in a particularly tricky
situation they do just seem to think
that they can keep testing and
containing their way out of this
however long term
it doesn't look very it doesn't look
very sustainable there is going to be a
political hit no matter what they can't
escape it
you